hallo meine lieben freund ich sitze hier
zusammen mit da da gesetz bereits in
titel eingeblendet und zwar reagiert
sandra heute auf meine verwandlung zur
drag queen und zwar bei der shorttrack
dabei und wurde zu einer dragqueen
geschminkt verwandelt et cetera
es war auf jeden fall so dass das video
eigentlich total bedeutet video mal wie
jedes andere von mir auch
also jetzt mal ganz ehrlich respekt die
frau die das schmink tja das ist krank
alter aber lokal sich so scheiße aus
alter aber irgendwie cool zu sehen alter
es ist wunderschön
nein ich hab davor noch nie gesehen er
muss man dazu sagen ich habe nicht
darauf warten musste ich reagieren kann
drauf nein nein nein nein nein nein das
kann nicht wahr sein nein null bis sexy
alter komme ich gar nicht klar gerade
bin sehr gespannt was er gleich sagen
dass dort zuerst machen wir noch zwei
[Musik]
einfach nur deutsches film altersklassen
stehen also das ist ja legendär luca
berg oder gar nicht auf seinem konto
diese wenn du so wie wenn ich ganz
normal heißt genau videos legendär hat
das eine traumfigur
man müsste das impfen weil du einfach
schon so aber jetzt über 70 schild okay
von der seite eins zu eins aus wie die
schwester sarah ein paar sekunden später
das ist sarah das ist sarah was ist das
alte rom ein
ich schwöre ich möchte ich ja dabei
gehöre alter der region manduca sieht
als mittel gar nicht so schlecht aus
alteration nicht vor
dadurch
würde ich sagen ja egal luca alter ein
neues team 600 oder was alter du bist
peinlich alter ich habe absolut nichts
dagegen wenn männer sich schminken für
dich im gegenteil für dich geil alter
weil ich mich aus schminkt aber so ein
typ zu sehen wie du keltert er sich das
klingt alter schon ein bisschen
ungewohnt zu sehen halte aber feines
junge alter des perfekten hüftschwung
alter luca alter es steht er wieder der
größte körper klaus alter was soll ich
dazu sagen
das war meine reaktion falls ihr wollt
dass ich nochmal reaction aufnehme dann
diesem video einen daumen hoch und
abonniert meinen kanal ich war jetzt
gerade draußen habe es anders reaction
nicht mitbekommen ich hoffe dennoch dass
ich irgendwie gefallen hat ich werde das
video jetzt hier gleich schneiden wir
wollten euch allerdings nur ganz kurz
sagen dass soeben ebenfalls eine neue
folge dick und doof online gegangen ist
dann gegangen
[Musik]